allora partiamo oggi con questo evento
pazzesco organizzato da mondadori per
insomma all'uscita secondo capitoli
detto vi ringrazio tantissimo perché se
siete qua vuol dire che avete
preordinato il libro e se avete per
ordinato il libro vuol dire che avete
avuto fiducia in me insomma delle mie
capacità
ma oggi è in questa chiamata abbiamo
selezionato una quindicina di domande e
quindi tiriamo dentro alcuni di voi
parliamo un po come se fosse uno miccoli
in live o di voi vedono il di mail fa
vige youtuber ma diciamo che io come
facevi video ma anche al di fuori della
mia vita sono ragazzo che mi piace
informarsi vedere cose film serie tv
legge quindi volevo creare un'opera
piacermi ma proprio da spettato al celio
nel senso voglio entrare in libreria da
mondadori e di rio voglio un libro così
vado e non lo trovo per come come si fa
ben ai lo scriviamo da allora ho scritto
dei gay già è stata l'idea che ha dato
il via a punto per the cage il prim
oggi è uscito il secondo molti di voi
hanno notato anche migliore
me lo state scrivendo e quindi non è che
mimì autoelogio anzi ci mancherebbe
salite nelle critiche io sono contento
di sentirlo ci mancherebbe altro però
mista mi hanno fatto notare molti di voi
mette fatto notare che il secondo libero
e più avvincente voci sono molti di cose
questo perché ho detto intanto vediamo
come va il primo è piaciuto e allora
plan partitico il secondo è ancora non
avete visto il terzo abbiamo selezionato
al comune adesso faremo entrare il primo
di voi che mi ha fatto una domanda
abbiamo scelto le più variegate insomma
per non dire sempre le stesse cose e
quindi il primo di oggi è il signor
lorenzo hai un nome che fa schifo per
ora no scherzando
però hai fatto una splendida domandarci
a valore di 1.000 innanzi tutto grazie
mille ciao a te nun se a te e la tua
domanda era da questa ti è venuta l'idea
di scrivere il sequel
di bill gates giusto allora fai che il
primo libro io allora in realtà è stata
io non sono uno scrittore quindi io non
ho scritto un libro da scrittore che ho
scritto quello che io avrei voluto
leggere quindi ho messo giù una trama
bella lunga e poi ho detto diventa un
libro ma non so fino a che punto si
ferma diciamo chiuda il primo sarebbe
andato già avanti c'è una prima metà di
questo libro sarebbe già dovuta essere
il primo nella mia testa poi a livello
editoriale un casino il sequel non mi è
venuto del sequel era già scritto a
livello idea
poi quando l'ho scritto ho rielaborato
un po tutto ecc perché dunque dall
uscita del primo ad oggi sono passati
tre anni e mai caduto tre anni il tempo
corre un po in fretta per il raduno da
un film a coppia quando abbiamo fatti
più fatto no e chi lo fa ma ho fatto
l'ho fatto dovrà fare il quello il sotto
le cuffie trovato vicino
l'ho messo vicino perfetta ecco questa è
la questa ragazzina e la mia mano io
sono sicuro di avercela infatti c'è no
ragazzi siamo vecchi guarda guarda come
firmavo bene non che adesso sia cambiata
la faccenda però la forza se ora sul
computer mi voglio neanche vedere va
bene perche tu mi hai scritto
come ti è venuto in mente di scrivere un
romanzo e perché proprio con questa
trama corretto l'hai detto tu esaltante
c'è stata la parte che vedo che tu leggi
parecchio lì dietro quindi crescere
spiega fatati infatti anche tu avrai
insomma un giudizio che pesa perché se
sei una lettrice vuol dire che saprei
dare un vero giudizio quindi mi aspetto
che tu non lo scriva in direct ringrazio
per la domanda e ti ringrazio per aver
ordinato il libro in realtà il romanzo
penso tutti i tedeschi in generali e che
quindi primo perché secondo me è venuto
in mente perché ho fatto il primo per
forza e dove come il primo mi è venuto
in mente perché in realtà in partito
sembra semplice ma che ora sta
inventando sta roba da te vero è partito
da un sogno perché di notte alle 4 del
mattino mi son svegliato detto no fatto
uso un incredibile fatti chissà cosa mi
bevo che andare a dormire e ho sognato
più o meno quella che può essere
considerato il binario di the cage 1
ho detto wow fissi iniziato a scrivere
la la bozza la bozza della bozza della
bozza della bozza leather che i giorni
proprio per il fatto che come ho già
detto prima mi sono ispirato anche a
vari libri e se le tv che ho visto
quindi tutte le cose ha detto mondadori
guarda questo che figo mondadori ha
detto che figo
si sono d'accordo è pensa io per tu mio
canale per caso quindi penso si aspetta
aspetta che qua ci hai delle robe che mi
piacciono
la maglia firmata ai fossero attaccato
dietro simili questo è stato una prima
vento al fino a copie di the cage
ok e vabbè dovevamo qua eravamo al
mondatori di milano è visto nessuno a
casa tua
lei è proprio lei ha vinto lei era
comandato riassume teano e allora basta
leggere domande di chi ha chiesto se per
sé per fare i personaggi ti sei ispirato
a delle parti
2 c'è di te stesso perché probabilmente
tu hai non so io ho fatto delle ipotesi
ok diciamo partiamo da questo
presupposto
ho pensato che tu magari ti sei il posto
la domanda ok io sono in questa
situazione come reagisco e per ogni
personaggio tu hai dato una reazione che
tu avresti fatto né in quella situazione
va bene giorgia grazie prossima domanda
fa scherzando
sì per quanto riguarda la questione del
trovarsi in una determinata circostanza
nel senso che il mio protagonista di the
cage sono io un nome diverso
va beh quella notte a un capitolo è
quello con questo non ci piove
e quindi li era per me è stato facile
immedesimarmi nelle varie circo nelle
varie situazioni nelle varie circostanze
comunque non sono tutti personaggi
legati alla mia personalità perché se
non sarei quello de split che ne ha 27 e
non perché sono veramente quello c'è il
bullo c'è la ragazza è innamorata cioè
quella che il manager è impazzito adesso
me ne vado
ma resta no o crea in realtà tutti i
personaggi che ho creato all'infuori di
ray me li sono inventati di sana pianta
ed è stato utile perché ho preferito
ispirarmi tanto a me stesso per il
protagonista sembra egocentrica la cosa
ma veramente l'ho fatto perché almeno
capisco come si possa ritrovare come può
reagire protagonista in determinate
situazioni
essendo molto simile a me gli altri no
non c'è nessuno le sua persona in
particolare la quale mi sono ispirato è
andata completamente di fantasia e ho
immaginato in quella situazione
che tipi di persone avrebbe potuto
incontrare il protagonista in questo
caso però è aperto un lavoro stupendo
anch'io elenco abbastanza il secondo mi
sta piacendo di più del primo
grazie o alto di più gravi il primo è
stato bello perché sai inizio in cui il
cavolo entry nell'ottica è tutto giulia
è così si perdonano inizia miss come
stai bene grazie tu come stai io bene
thai le cuffie che sono particolari per
due motivi la prima quelle vengono
utilizzate negli elicotteri e la
spagnola il colore e la seconda sembrano
uguali alle mie più a quelle che aveva
una volta col filo rosso riusciva solo
che sono tutte grigie nel caso ci fai
caso veramente titolo adesso può
iniziare a fare gli ide one ha iniziato
quella youtuber no in realtà faceva
picto che non so se inizi ti ricordi di
me io sono stata la prima che immesso
nel tuo video del reaction ai vostri
video a casa quella che ha fatto la
reticente quella che fatto la vita da
tutti hanno fatto qualche cosa di simile
cose che hai fatto è praticamente era
tipo voiceover nou dove facevo finta di
ha sì sì sì sì sì sì sì sì ok aspettano
presente adesso si sia adesso si è
infatti riconosciuta dalla voce in
realtà non dà alla mia voce
ma niente allora dimmi tu la domanda con
larghezza consiglio fabi spero che siamo
well
ok filing embratur d'accordo volevo
chiederti se ci fosse afferma
parte in quei detto no ok ho un blocco o
perché era emotivamente difficile
continuare oppure dire vai fucino per
dire oppure una parte in cui ti sei
bloccato perchè dici ma adesso come
continuo per farla bene questa questa
questa parte eccetera
ma allora innanzitutto ti dico che tu
sei seguitissima ceneri lasciate la
gente sta impazzendo cioè ma allora chi
segue se guardi ti sei la guarda se io
ho una voce da doppiatrice tu sei una
doppiatrice se una tik tok air tra un po
diventa istituita resto sarà soltanto
una sua grande fan che ci mettiamo
d'accordo
tu dall'anno prossimo file video al
posto mio qua io ho finito il canale fai
tu perché hai tutte cartiere così si
impara tante le guarda ed è diventato il
tuo il tuo evento ma che scusa è giusto
così ti rispondo che sono andiamo per le
mega lunger il blocco non ce l'ho
propriamente avuto e ce l'ho avuto tra
il primo e secondo perché ti ho detto
c'era questo questo progetto del secondo
libro che era strettamente legato anche
al fatto di che sarebbe poi uscita una
serie tv e quindi si è dilungato
parecchio io volevo già me volevo fare
una stesura del secondo libro ma ero
molto imitato capito quindi ho avuto
questo blocco tra il primo e il secondo
libro anche se il progetto non era
avviato in qualcosa volevo già scrivere
e quindi non sapevo se farlo o meno però
quando tu hai un'idea ti conviene questo
in generale ma un consiglio se passiamo
anche te che fai tic toc e se poi l'idea
per un tic toc chi viene fusino che stai
festeggiano questa insidia scrivi tal
subito nelle note per modalità
dimentichi quindi il blocco lo puoi
arginare dal momento in cui tu ottimizzi
tutti i tuoi ragionamenti artistici
cento in questo momento sei ti stai
lavando i denti e ti viene un'idea
mentre c'hai ancora dentifricio prende
il telefono e descrive questo qua ti per
questa cosa ti permette di creare i
punti fermi nella tua mente per stato
molto importante in questo momento
stiamo per fare visto che se non
riusciamo ad includerci tutti mai
io sono furbo e riesco a fare una cosa
in particolare
io vorrei visto che quelli che sono
entrati adesso abbiamo massimizzato
vorrei fare una mega foto per favore con
il libro quindi se voi avete libro in
questo momento melo melo prendete bravi
me lo prendete e io io farò una foto
mega a tutti quanti che avete il libro
vi alzate tutti così per favore 3 2 1
cioè 21 13 21 tranne uno le più e stato
bellissimo sentirmi io spero
innanzitutto che vi sia piaciuto
l'evento speriamo insomma vi sia
piaciuto tutto è stata che noia sono
d'accordo io mi sono innamorato di
questo progetto che sono andava rifatto
grazie e vi saluto
vi mando un bacio grazie della
chiacchiera e di luglio va bene tutti
quanti ragazzi vogliono dell anima
grazie aveva creduto nel progetto
sindaco un bacio a tutti e grazie anche
ovviamente a mondadori
[Musica]